when i was 15 a boy during the pledge of
allegiance
goes hey reika uh you know john's
john smith wants you to know you have a
nice piece of ass and i went home
and i donated all of my pants to the
salvation army
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast i
am your host your roast coming queen
a girl who absolutely pretended
to understand what donnie darko was
about elise morales and with
us today guys we've got such a good
friend we got an
old friend she's a comedian and actress
you recognize her from college humor the
between two ferns movie auntie donna's
big old house of fun and she was also
one of jfl's 2020 new faces but before
all of that
she was a graduate of conestoga high
school
it's ray kashenko
yes that's my biggest achievement
hey listen we put in a lot of work to
get that high school degree
it really honestly i mean i'm sure
people talk about this but like the
amount of work i had to do for ap
classes in high school was unbelievable
and then when i went to college it was
like
okay i guess thank you because like now
this is much easier
yeah i um i can't remember what episode
we were talking about this on but
the terms of high school like i would
never
accept that as a job today they were
like you get up at six a.m
you you work all day
then you go home there's more work and
you've got to finish it
yes yes you have to finish it there
are you and it's all in different
subjects none of them will bleed over
into each other
there's nothing you do for one class
that suffices for another it's all
completely different
yes it's actually that you work for 15
departments
at once yes exactly you have 15 jobs
you're like accounts payable
you're marketing you're also the
spokesperson you also are the copywriter
and the ceo
[Laughter]
truly like everything is your department
you're responsible for everything
you have homework you have work when you
get back from school and it's also not
okay to like
just be involved in the stuff you do
during the day you really are supposed
to stay
and do like you have to do
extracurriculars you have to yeah like
and then on the weekend you gotta go
other places
and then you got people who are asking
you for being on the phone for six hours
with your friend
and you're like okay exactly exactly
it's
i would not again i would never accept
those
three things
for absolutely zero pay well
wow so i always like to start off by
asking um
conestoga high school well first of all
what was your mascot
we were the pioneers or the generals how
was your pioneer
uh fashioned i think it was like
a like a [ __ ] skin hat
like like real davey crockett looking
[ __ ]
yep um and what like flavor of high
school was it like
public private sports focused
academic what's the what's the student
body
makeup etc yes so we were a public
school
and at the time that i went we were like
the number one public school in
pennsylvania
hello um we were super
academic focused but also uh had a
really good like crew
team um and i'm sure other sports teams
but that's always the one i heard
um but yeah like we the
the circle i was into was so ap focused
i took like
13 aps in high school and
that was like low my friends most of my
friends took like around 15 i would say
what what aps did you take let's go and
play
for asking okay so freshman year
i was uh uh i didn't take any and that
was like
whoa because a lot of my friends were
just like we're gonna take ap bio
freshman year even though that was a
sophomore year class
oh i was trying to think i was like were
there
aps available freshman year and i think
ap bio
yes was the one and you know what at my
school
the year before us they changed it for
our year and it was so sad
if you did ap bio you got to
train a baby duck
you could train it to do anything yeah
you could train it
anything
[Laughter]
they you as a as an ap bio student you
got a baby duck
and that you it was like i i don't know
they were teaching it about responses i
don't know but you had got to train your
baby duck to do a trick
that is i while i would have loved to
participate in that i do think it is
excellent that they discontinued that
that song
absolutely not first of all my parents
would have been
pissed if i brought home a duck
absolutely not
yeah of course also like are all of
those ducks traumatized after that
experience
probably what happens to them after and
now they know this trick
and now we oh you've you you you rolled
over and now we put you straight into
the trash
like what happened to the ducks after
that's i don't know
yeah we oh man we didn't have anything
like that but like ap bio was the thing
it's like you were really smart freshman
year you took ap bio and i was like
my god and when i was in eighth grade or
sorry when i was in
this is not high school but in sixth
grade after
uh the year ended my teacher recommended
i go to above
math there was like above on and below
level math and middle school
yeah and i was like i was not confident
at math at all
uh and i was like well are there
materials i could do over the summer
gave me a packet i did all this work
over the summer
and then the first day of seventh grade
math i was like i won't be able to do
this
so i dropped myself down to on level
math
really even after you did all the work
i know and my teacher approached me i
want to say
once a week for two months and he's like
i really think you should move up
i was like nice try i'm too stupid
sorry excuse me i'm too dumb and so i
stayed in that level math the whole year
and then at the end of that year he was
like you have to move up a level and i
was like
fine well is there work i could do over
the summer
and so he lent me a textbook and i did
all this work over the summer and then i
went to like
these there was above and then there was
above above
so i went to the first level of above
math for eighth grade and i was
fine um
[Laughter]
yes this feeds into like i thought i was
too dumb freshman year to like do a
bunch of stuff
the ability like when you're a kid
to just like spiral out on something and
think that like
the consequences are going to be so bad
like
like i would love to go talk to sixth
grade reika and be like
what do you think is gonna happen you're
in a slightly more advanced
math class than like you're necessarily
prepared for but it would have
you were like i couldn't possibly do
that i truly was like
i will feel so stupid and i will fail
out of this class because like anything
that intimidated me on day one
it's so done the whole point of the
class is like you learn stuff you didn't
know
but if someone said like a word i didn't
know it's like i'm too stupid for this
class
or whatever yeah like it's like you're
supposed to learn in the classroom
granted there are definitely times where
people end up in a class that's like too
much for them
totally but like i would venture to say
i was too stupid to know if something
was too hard for me
um so i should have chilled out
because yeah freshman year like i didn't
take any ap classes i took all honors
classes i even because i was so
self-conscious about that math thing
i took an elective math class which like
which meant i had to take two math
i know and then uh sophomore year
i took what the algebra what no what the
[ __ ] algebra 2 bc
which is such a weird terminology that
only like math classes get did you have
like a b
math and bc math yes i remember we had
b c calc yes bc
i did not get
[Laughter]
so i was in algebra bc which is a huge
jump
from what i was doing before and that
class was too hard i got like
b pluses which was like not normal for
me
and uh oh my god so i took that which
counted kind of like ap but there was no
ap test
an ap bio that year and ap euro
i remember ap euro which i did not take
because i was still too nervous
yeah i started taking my ap classes my
like junior
year yes i think that uh
is normal and my high school was like
extremely competitive
and you always knew everybody else's
[ __ ] like even in my ap bio class i
actually what's so crazy about me being
like i'm too dumb for this that
single-handedly is the class i [ __ ]
destroyed it
out of like any class in high school i
got like a hundred percent
every semester i [ __ ] nailed that
class
but they would like post your grades and
they would put your student id number
next to it
as if that was obscuring it at all
because i was like i know
michael and i are competing for number
one so i know what his student id
it's so stupid yeah i am i still
remember my high school student id
number because
well i'll meet you seventeen oh two
seven one zero
one three one one three three one yes
and i would have to type it in to get a
cookie
just like i will never forget it
so funny um
yeah so that was sophomore junior oh by
the way after sophomore year i went to
biomedical research camp for a summer
that's the only
sleep boy camp i've ever been to okay so
now now you're partying now
now i'm letting loose as a teen i'm not
yeah
i'm going to sleep away camp with
lecture in the morning and lab in the
afternoon
biomedical research camp absolutely and
i requested
a single dorm because again i was very
nervous
and i and i also was like i don't need
any more friends
[Music]
even more to learn i was very
extroverted i don't know why i was so
i think i was just like i'm never going
to meet anyone as cool as my current
friend so like i don't need any new
friends
uh give me a single room that's so funny
because usually the point of
camp is to be like i'm gonna go to camp
and meet a whole new group of friends
and be this new person who
i am at camp but you were like no i'm
here for
i'm here to learn i'm not here to make
friends
honestly in retrospect i understand the
decision because the people at that camp
with the exception of one
girl that i kept in touch with for a
long time were
weird uh biomedical research came i know
i was shocked and it was mostly men and
they were all disgusting
um yeah you know what actually i do
think we needed to put teen reika in
this private area let's just give her a
[ __ ] away
she's here to learn she doesn't i
actually have turned turned around on
this 100
and i'm like actually you know what you
were keeping yourself safe
and happy because they were like i have
no problem with like nerds i'm talking
about like those smarmy
dudes that were like i'm smart and
popular
there were some guys like that there and
i remember once they found out that i
brought the seinfeld dvds with me
and they were like do you want to do a
viewing party in my dorm
and i said no
and then he's like fine [ __ ] it's like
cool
i think i think this is an incredible
age
so the picture that i'm getting now of
teen reika
she's alone at biomedical research camp
watching the seinfeld dvds
yeah that's true and i brought three
songs with me my dad lent me his laptop
so i could do work
and i put three songs on what were the
songs
[ __ ] it was uh was don't panic by
coldplay on like the garden state
soundtrack or some [ __ ] like that
that sounds correct it was some cold
play ask
song if it wasn't that specifically remy
zero
um whatever song was on the like oc like
whatever oh california like
not that song it was a hallelujah fair
fair it was called fair uh yes and then
um
snow patrol run three pretty sad songs
then you would just listen to those and
watch the seinfeld dvds and learn about
biomedical research
absolutely and i wrote a paper on cystic
fibrosis by the end
incredible and so and you were
not as academically dedicated as some of
your friends
i think so because all my friends had
ended up at ivs and like like
wellesley williams like all these like
iv
uh adjacent liberal schools and stuff i
was like
among the dumber of my friends if they
listen to they'd be like no you're not
like yes i was
uh shut up just let me say this
yes because like i just had to work so
much harder to do the same
things like i was studying all the time
i did [ __ ] like i would take notes and i
would tape it in my
shower while i was showering so i could
never stop studying
uh [ __ ] like that because otherwise i
just wouldn't get the same grades as
them i was studying all the time
and i like uh uh like yeah like junior
year i took ap
psych ap us ap what the [ __ ] did i take
ap us was my big one that i crushed yeah
oh i totally buy that i i was surprised
i did well in
ap us because history is not my subject
but i think it helps that you
um basically take us history from first
grade
yeah um uh i will say that i did uh i
did take ap us history in the in the
commonwealth of virginia and so i
learned some things that i would say are
incorrect but
but ultimately i did crash the class oh
yeah [ __ ] yeah i mean
i think if anyone takes ap us history
you always
learn some things that are incorrect
yeah and it's actually a fun game that
you play for the rest of your life
to kind of one of them will pop up and
you'll be like oh my god
that wasn't right at all oh i thought
that event was good
and it was actually very bad oh yeah i
remember reading about japanese
internment
in my u.s history textbook and i do
remember it was
it wasn't a huge section it was like a
couple paragraphs
and then when i learned what the
severity of japanese internment was i
was like
this was so recent guys well it's also
like it would be one of those things
where it's like
you have the regular part of the
textbook and then it's in like a
different little box
did you know yeah did you know that we
put
people in and it's just like that's
like something that's extra yeah that's
like if you care to look at the
footnotes or the sidebar
there's a little history book with a
face that's like did you
yeah exactly you heard a little owl yeah
atrocities yeah we had our own version
of camps
like truly mortifying
um right we do get to this point on
every podcast where we're just screaming
about like the history classes we took
and like
how we didn't learn anything correctly
so do you think your goal when you were
when you were like doing
all these classes what's your goal
because you felt like you wanted to keep
up with your friends was it because you
wanted to get into a good college
was it that you you like just didn't
know what else
to do i think yeah i wanted to i
definitely wanted to keep up with my
friends because all my friends were
super smart i wanted to keep up with
like family members like older cousins
and stuff of mine that i saw get like
praised for
you know going to a good school all this
sort of stuff because like
i didn't tell you my dark past elise
which is i was a bad student at one
point
oh no elementary until fifth grade i was
a bad student i would cheat on all my
tasks i never studied i like didn't
i was completely like eyes pointing into
different directions like i don't even
think i knew what
what i what school was for what i was
doing what was your cheat
method yeah so during
um like i've never been a reader so like
during
um and now i read way more but like
especially in elementary school
in early middle school so we would do
this worldly wise textbook which was
like a vocab
and like reading comprehension thing and
my friend my best friend at the time was
a
super reader and so she would always be
like the first to finish and
she would just like not turn hers in yet
and kind of like
angle it toward me and do that kind of
[ __ ] that's a good friend though
listen we were that's a good [ __ ]
friend she didn't let me get held back
no she was like you know what underneath
this bad student reika
there's a good student reagan that's
maybe sick
but she's good exactly that's demented
and she was white so actually she's an
ally
and that's nice and that's what it
actually is and that's what it actually
is that's a beautiful allergy
so were your parents very
in like did they follow along with your
academics heavily
or i don't know so it's funny because
like i know there's a stereotype with
like a lot of asian and south asian
parents like oh they're very strict
my parents if you asked me if you asked
them like what
college i went to i i think my dad
my dad definitely knows my mom probably
can guess like they
they are so oblivious they did not pay
attention at all they were never like
hey did you do your homework they are
not aware
it is not like the thing like hey don't
you have a test young lady
not a chance in hell did they know any
single thing i had to be doing
so they were never like wow are you not
doing your homework
like it wasn't that nobody cared it's
just they had no like discipline like
i've never been grounded like
none of that so that's so all of that
was
self generally absolutely i literally
remember the day
in sixth grade i went home and i was
like
i am not a good student
and i opened my um
my social studies textbook and i think
it was something on
the uk i think it was it hadn't even
been assigned yet
and i was like what if just a test what
if i read this chapter and like take
notes and like learn and at the end of
that week there was a pop
quiz by that time we had been assigned
the chapter but i had like
three extra days to marinate on this or
whatever
and i got a 10 out of 10 on it or
something something
meaningless but i was like wow
i can do it and you just wanted that
high
ever since that's 10 out of 10 i mean
listen
there was a feeling of like getting your
paper back and like
seeing a good grade on it and like your
teacher
drawing a little star or something that
like
how do i get that back in my adult life
literally how do i get that back i can't
even get
a job to tell me they've rejected me
yeah it's like i can't even get negative
feedback
absolutely just sending stuff out into
the void was it good we have no idea
it's i remember went back in ninth grade
when i was like uh
having a really just not good time and
then
i studied for this one test i had like a
come to jesus
meeting with my teachers and they were
like good they were like you don't need
to be failing this class you probably
actually like this class and i was like
yeah i think you're right
yeah so i did well on this
test about greek history and i remember
my teacher wrote like
welcome back that is test
and i was like oh my god
and i felt it i felt like i was back it
it is so crazy how was like
those little tests or triumphs as a teen
or a kid like really stick out were you
a good test test taker in general
see i guess it's like my definition is
different because to me a good test
taker all my friends were good test
takers
uh didn't really need to study very much
i needed to study so it wasn't i was
never like i'm a good test taker i'm
like i studied my
ass off i guess my definition would
be more about like
um do you feel like you did you did you
feel like you knew
what like a test wanted from you because
i felt like i had
very i had a lot of friends who were
really really smart but they had test
anxiety
yeah and they had a really hard time
like they would get overwhelmed with
like the multiple choice
of it at all whereas i was very like
i can see that i felt very like
like i could tell what the test was
trying to say i was like oh
i think i can see the little clues to
the answer in this
i think that's awesome i was not like
that because i don't think i had
critical thinking skills or the ability
to read um
i think uh i don't think i got like
tremendous test anxiety but when i took
a test i was very like
i could miss those little like road maps
and stuff i like remember once during an
ap
lang test um
this is such a like a deliciously high
school thing
where someone goes up to the teacher in
the middle of the test and points
something out
and then the teacher goes um for number
answer choice c should say this
and then there's a collective oh you
would only be correcting that if that
was the correct answer
interesting yeah exactly and like
i would get that but i would get that
like four seconds later than everybody
else
because i was like what is the rate and
then they're like no
uh why would you need to correct a wrong
answer in a multiple choice like
section or whatever yeah like why would
it be important
yes for this to change yes
here's okay here's a story from ap
history world is um i remember for i
think the ap us
the a push test there was like an app
there was a
aspect of the test where you had to read
some
original documents um are you talking
about a dbq
yes oh my god i completely forgot that's
what it's called
okay the dbq um
i just like one of the documents i just
couldn't figure out
how to work it in so i just cited it
randomly next to a random sentence and i
got a five on that exam
listen i those things okay i will say
when it came to essay writing i was a
good test taker i could figure out the
like
stuff that made it look like a good
essay yeah and i do think in a dbq that
that skill kind of shines because you
can like pick out what the
important quotes are even if you don't
quite understand it
usually dbqs from one eye
from like ap era i remember the big
thing they taught you was like
the point of this is that you know every
document
has bias so if you are reading about the
lutheran reformation
and you are reading a document and then
you see it as written by a pope
you know like there is bias and you have
to critically think about that document
if only everyone had taken
and honestly i literally do think about
that a lot because i'm like
yeah so like twitter is just the biggest
dbq of our lives
it's really wow it really really is
um okay let's pivot and talk about
i mean not that this isn't your social
life but let's talk about
the crew we actually have some photos
here so let's pull up these
photos yes let's talk about
so this first one gives me strong
like birthday party sleepover what's
happening here
yeah i'm pretty sure this is
this is either a pool party of a friend
of mine and it's like
too cool it's not actually a pool party
but he just has a pool kind of thing
because we're all wearing like winter
clothes
um yeah i think this is like a birthday
party these are definitely my like
latter half of high school friends i
will say the two people on either side
of me
um i just did a secret santa with them i
am still extremely close with them
that's beautiful we love to see that
here on the rose yes
uh the the woman to my left the girl to
my left is like has been my best friend
since i was uh
11 and same with the person on my right
um
the person that we're talking to i had a
cable access tv show with
in high school wow oh my god in high
school
yeah that was we had a tv class which
was really cool and i thought maybe i'm
too dumb for this
if you notice a pattern that's
really we had a tv class too but i
didn't take it is that
what made you go on the path of wanting
to be in television and going to nyu
and so when i was
uh when i was 15 i was
disgustingly obsessed with larry david
like and jerry seinfeld i celebrated
their birthdays like it's a whole mess
and and i remember because this was when
you could start to read about your faves
online
and i read that larry david carried a
little notebook around with him to take
notes on and that like how he got
started in tv and i was like oh that
sounds really cool and i remember a
friend of mine not pictured here was
like you should go to nyu film i was
like a [ __ ]
why i will never i don't know anything
about that
and as i got into high school
you know there were tv classes i thought
it was a lot of fun i started editing
uh and i was like this is a blast but i
surely can't do this for a living uh
and then when i got to college i applied
as like pre-med
and then i immediately switched to film
because i hated it
okay so you got it you were like
you you wanted to be like near it
basically but you weren't ready
i wasn't ready to commit yeah so in that
picture too
i wanted to point out a deeply important
high school story
yes is that so those pants that i'm
wearing they are from
the urban outfitters sale section great
and
and the shirt the two shirts and let me
tell you at least probably three shirts
i'm wearing
were hand-me-downs from my uh cousin and
my two things were i loved free [ __ ] and
i was shorter than everybody i knew
so they always gave me their [ __ ] uh or
their clothes especially my friend
that's on my left hand side
uh and when i was 15
a boy during the pledge of allegiance
i sat down uh and
the guy that sat next to him went up to
sharpen his pencil
and he goes hey reika uh you know john's
john smith wants you to know you have a
nice piece of ass
and that was not how i perceived myself
and i turned around and he went like
this and i like call me
and i was like what image am i
portraying to the world
um and i went home and i donated
all of my pants to the salvation army
and i started buying pants that were
like
three to four sizes too big for me
including these pants which you can't
even see my
legs in uh i could pull these pants down
while they were buttoned
and zipped uh they were very large
and yes oh my god
that i mean there's so much like
sweetness
to that story and like
first of all this like this teenage
boy's first attempt at harassment
i know which is beautiful which is
beautiful
he's he's learning something new you're
learning something now
yeah it's really nice and this is
exactly why i
uh loved the boys at camp
they're all equal level of intelligence
to this man
were did you have a lot of crushes at
this time or
you did okay tons of crushes but i never
saw them through i didn't have my first
kiss so i was 23 years old
and like yeah i was like
i was so like no one would want to date
me so i'm just going to keep this all
contained and like i didn't like my body
and the idea that it was changing was
really uncomfortable to me
and like in an asian family they often
don't tell you anything like when i got
my period
the first thing my mom said was about
maxi pads and she never she's never said
the word tampon
not not kosher cannot no
and then i did literally said just
please don't tell anyone
she said okay seven seconds later
she's like telling my siblings
it's really yes um absolute immediacy
and then my dad came home and he was so
uncomfortable and he
pulled out a bouquet of roses and i was
like
no and it was something clearly he had
been told to do by somebody else he was
like uh
here and i was like please so i was
always so uncomfortable with all the
changes happening
and just a line of deeply misguided men
leading to your dad giving you roses
when you're like i
really would just rather you not talk to
me for the next 36 hours
truly and it was horrible and then after
this
incident with that guy in the homeroom
my friends
and bless them because they're also like
they they don't know this and they would
probably be mortified
but they would be like and they thought
it was a compliment they're like reika
you should love your body your body's
great
i was like no shut up they literally
once at i think my birthday
bounced quarters off of my ass to be
like look it's great
i mean it seems like your ass was really
making a splash rika
yeah i had a debut
cause this boy is like i mean the boys
are talking about it your friends are
talking about yeah
it was a big deal because then that was
also and this is such a tragic moment to
me of childhood
when you start not being able to share
clothes with your friends
like your bodies are changing and like
this is with my friend like i've always
had friends that were super
tall and i was always short like you'd
never share but my friends who i could
share with
it was like oh no i'm getting an ass you
are
thin as a rail and yeah model
for me i was i was constantly
my my brain was consumed at all waking
hours with the fact that i don't have
giant boobs
and i was just like this how am i going
to move forward
if i don't ever get giant boobs and then
it turns out like it's fine
it turns out it's fine
[Laughter]
is there again if there are any teens
listening to this
um and you don't have giant boobs it's
fine and if you do have giant boobs it's
fine it's also fun both of them are fine
it's all great yeah and then
and you can change them also if you want
that's actually literally true
it's also like it's fine it's nobody's
business and you can shop in whatever
section you can shop in
whatever gender section and honestly
because i was on the short whatever age
section my friends used to make fun of
me for shopping in the kids section i'm
like i am so much shorter than you
uh all these adult clothes to this day
my like my uh uh brother got me like a
shirt or whatever and it's like an adult
small or whatever extra small i'm like
okay my boobs are too big for this and
my body is too short goes down like
past my ass like
i like it took me so long to realize
like other people are built differently
or like
i mean one for me that was huge
was my hair like because i was so into
like the emo
lifestyle and i did not understand
why i could not get my hair
as straight as avril lavigne's like why
can't i get my hair to be
the same as this canadian white woman
and yes one day i brought a picture of
her
like into my salon when i was 13 and
julia my stylist
shout out to her she was like babe
you're latina
like this is not happening you have
curly really thick
curly hair like you're not this is never
gonna happen for you and i was like
finding out you have curly hair it
sounds like something you should know
earlier but i did it and i wanted to
look like ryan stevens
and it didn't happen for me and i would
try to do my hair like that i would like
wet i would tie it in a thousand
scrunchies so it would just be straight
yeah i asked my mom for a straightener
and she said
no um i talked to a girl about
chemically straightening and she said do
not do
it all my hair fell out
the only representation of curly hair
that existed
was to those completely
crunched like you know the
the completely gel crunched curl
that was like girls at my school when
they wanted to have curly hair they
would do that
and it would be like their hair the
hardest hair
yeah yes or it would be all
i remember when straight haired girls
would curl their hair and i was like
imposter you have no idea what it's like
[Laughter]
you come in my house yeah
you come into my house with my hair
so were you going to the dances
and stuff at this time did you go with a
friend how did you how did you work all
of that out
yeah so god i went to
i went to school dances because i just
thought they would be fun and i liked
like
singing with my friends and stuff like
that never danced with a boy
um uh freshman year did i go to like
i might have gone to homecoming
sophomore year i might have gone to
homecoming again
junior year i went to junior prom um
and this was like it's like
75 because it includes dinner
get out of here um it was fine i bought
a dress from
like [ __ ] nordstrom rack or some [ __ ]
whatever fancy stories at the moment my
prom dress was from cachet
oh yes okay
i remember someone got like a custom
dress at some like
boutique and it was like wow
i i can't even fathom uh
so like i did do dances but i think
actually one of the pictures shows
it might look like i'm at a school dance
no no
uh i was part of what was it
in the national honor society i think we
got to do like volunteer stuff
and there we go and you can see my same
friend on my right and then my other
best friend on my left who i also did
the secret santa with i was all
four of us um and i do want to point out
that you are once again wearing
two shirts and giant pants okay
please these pants were from
urban outfitters sale section and they
were
a size i want to say 10.
i could pull them down completely
buttoned and zipped up it was a type of
thing where when you belt it
if i had a belt which i didn't i was
using my grandfather's belt that he had
taped together
until my friend made me a belt because
she was like you need a [ __ ]
dial um where it like doubles back
on itself because it's so like big i
just hated
anyone looking at me those sandals were
my mom she gave me
um i am wearing two shirts because
this was the ymca dance the y dances
these were
very popular social events for me and my
friends
you can see uh my two friends in the
back wearing red shirts
um uh in theory we should all be wearing
some sort of volunteer shirt but we
would volunteer at eighth grade dances
in high school
every friday night because they were so
[ __ ] fun because we would just dance
we would do nothing and then we'd get
like free
punch and snacks and dance at this
stupid party and we did this so
often this is just one of many evenings
so your social life was to watch the
eighth graders
party yeah dancing but you would dance
as well
exactly honestly that's like that feels
like a great
[ __ ] deal you found a way to go to a
dance
with your friends regularly where
like the social life of your hours
and look good on college applications
and
and look [ __ ] styling at the dance
yeah well honestly i um
i applaud it thank you thank you um all
right let's roll through the rest of
these
photos i think there's like like one or
two more we have
yes okay great this is actually the
first photo of me
ever put on facebook wow
and this is in my backyard uh and i am
wearing my middle school gym shirt
shorts and a spongebob t-shirt so
this oh a classic look
spongebob fashion was huge though can i
say that
if you wanted to like project to your
schoolmates that you
were fun and you were cool like
you had a spongebob t-shirt so this was
from five below
and weirdly i got two of the same shirt
for my birthday from two different
friends from five below so i had two of
this shirt
and i didn't like how i looked in shorts
and so i just wore my gym shorts
uh those are middle school gym shorts
but this picture was taken in 20 2005
uh or when i was 15 or whatever um
uh so those shorts i had since i was
nine i got those shorts when i was nine
years old
and went to my new middle school having
moved from connecticut
and i was so short and small uh the gym
teacher gave me
the shorts and i had to roll them up
like seven times because they were so
large and
but by age 15 i really filled out these
middle school shorts nicely
with my gigantic ass and that was kind
of your first
well that was your first foray into
wearing huge pants into wearing huge
pants exactly
but later in life when you get sexually
harassed you're like you know what i've
actually i actually have in my
possession a solution to this problem
and it's to wear enormous pants it's
swearing where's pants and what's nice
about these middle school gym shorts is
they double as bathing suit bottoms and
now when you go to a pool party and you
don't know how to swim
you wear these pups and you just stick
your legs in and you look yes
and then your friend tells you lovingly
hatefully
you should wear a burkini and cover your
whole body
and you go yes
[Laughter]
you're like no that's funny that's funny
um uh so this is me building a tent in
my backyard we would call it going
tenting
and we would build a tent in my backyard
and do a sleepover there and
actually that is how i used to wake up
ludicrously early i'd wake up at like 5
00 a.m on my own accord or 6am
and so i woke up before all of my
friends and i went inside and i was like
let me watch tv and the thing that was
on was garden state so that's how i saw
it
and i was like this movie wasn't very
good
i did not understand it
why is he acting like this why was she
acting like that did he
[ __ ] kill his mom yeah i don't like
the chance
yeah i don't think they're
good couples yeah exactly
yeah we are coming up on the end now so
we've got this picture of tea and reika
um she's studying
she loves seinfeld yeah she's wearing
big-ass pants
she's got giant pants she maybe needs to
relax a little bit
absolutely um if you could talk
to teen reika today yeah what would you
tell her
i would say you need to look up people
with curly hair so you can stop feeling
like [ __ ] about your curly hair
and look up people with your body type
and stop looking at people who don't
genetically have your body type i would
say those two things
yeah having an ass is okay you just need
to understand your ass
and not fight your ass um
that you're allowed to feel uh pretty
that you are not as stupid as you
think you are um and
that
oh i didn't shave my legs until i was a
senior in high school
and a lot of friends gave me [ __ ] about
that and so i think i would tell my
friends to [ __ ] off i
literally one of my friends apologized
like recently for that she's like i'm
sorry i told you to shave your legs in
high school
i would literally shave them as a
present for people like oh my god
a birthday present and i would wear a
skirt and be like here you got what you
wanted
um i mean i could if i had had a friend
who wasn't shaving her legs i would have
been like you have to do it
because people just did and it didn't
even strike me as weird that my friends
were telling me that but i think i would
be like hey
we can all rel and i think in turn i
would not judge my friends i would try
not to be judgmental my friends who were
shaving their legs
uh because i think i did be like oh you
think you're an adult now
you're gonna try you're gonna start
kissing everybody now
you'd be behind you know
what it is a very visible symbol of like
who's becoming a sexual being
oh my god and who is not doing that yet
the day my friend my first friend went
on her first date
i was like oh my god so cool and once we
got off the phone i wept
[Laughter]
uh it's yeah it's tough i mean i
remember there being like a divide in my
friend group
when people started like doing stuff
versus who hadn't done any stuff totally
and it was painful for everyone on both
sides it is painful and i think i would
tell that person like hey
it is okay what they're doing is okay
and what you're doing is
also okay uh well i think that's
beautiful right guys i think that's a
perfect place for us to end it
um thank you so much for doing the pod
this was amazing thank you for having me
and for everyone listening at home this
has been the roast of your teenage self
podcast
hell yeah
you